is National Children's Dental Health
month but let's be honest we know not
every child loves going to the dentist
but we have some advice for parents to
help make the process easier and ensure
good hygiene so joining us today we have
Dr Michael cottam with Roseman Dental
thank you so much for being here it's
wonderful to be here so I know this is
probably a struggle for parents getting
their kids to get out get to the dentist
but it's so important what advice do you
have for parents especially in those in
between times to make sure that their
kids are ensuring good hygiene so Dental
prevention is a lot like medical
prevention right the magic happens in
between time it's what you do at home
that keeps you healthy between visits
not at visits so there are two things
that are really in our control that make
a huge difference and these aren't going
to be surprises to anyone one of them is
what you eat specifically sugar the more
you eat of it the more time that sugar
is in contact with your teeth the more
cavities you're going to find so one of
the things you can do is work on
controlling that Sugar just have less
sugar in your child's diet the second
one again not a surprise to anyone how
clean are your teeth brushing daily
specifically with a fluoride toothpaste
that's been shown to be Far and Beyond
the best thing to keep teeth healthy is
the fluoride and the toothpaste so
that's really important for parents to
keep in mind as they're shopping for
those toothpaste and I know they have
all the fun ones for the kids now but
most of those most of those have
fluoride in them okay but some people
are uncomfortable with fluoride and so
there are toothpastes out there that
don't have fluoride and the thing is
that if you're in communication with
your dentist your dentist can help you
navigate that stuff that's where the
visit comes in so the dentist if maybe
you don't like fluoride or you're having
trouble with the sugar and how do I get
my child to stop asking for for all of
the candy and the goodies between meals
right your dentist can help you discuss
strategies that work for you and kind of
customize that where health is the goal
and figure out what works for your
family that's really helpful and you are
located inside the cure for the kids
Foundation that's right right so you see
a lot of different families and children
come through so just as a final wrap up
here what is your your biggest piece of
advice if you could tell someone one
thing do this do this one thing go to
bed with with clean teeth I love that
all right brush your teeth before bed a
couple other helpful tips on your screen
there thank you so much Dr Michael for
being here we appreciate you all the
help all right Las Vegas